[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis sinken abend und willkommen
alles wichtige vom sport an diesem
sonntag von norbert könig
unsere großen themen heute
ukraine weitet offensiver aus
geländegewinne bei haacke bis nahe der
russischen grenze
letzte reise für die queen tausende
säumen die route durch schottland
und stark gestartet stark nachgelassen
deutschland erreicht mit mühe das
viertelfinale bei der basketball-em
die ukraine drängt die russischen
truppen im osten des landes weiter
zurück in deutschland werden daher aus
den ampel parteien forderungen lauter
dem land schnell weitere waffen zu
liefern nach ukrainischen angaben soll
das russische militär ein großteil des
gebiets hakes geräumt haben über das
kriegsgeschehen christoph des 3
die überreste einer russischen stellung
kündigt der ukrainische soldat für die
kamera an die filmt eine militärmütze
reste von essensrationen zurückgelassene
panzer bilder eines überstürzten
rückzugs raus aus ist um eine der
strategisch wichtigsten der von den
besatzern aufgegebenen städte bahngleise
gibt es und landstraßen kreuzen sich
hier im ganzen will die ukrainische
armee zuletzt 3000 quadratkilometer in
richtung osten befreit haben mehr
gebiete als russland in den letzten
monaten besetzen konnte
den ukrainischen vormarsch belegt wohl
auch eine flut an twitter videos immer
wieder zurück gelassene panzer aus der
luft russische kolonne unterwegs in
richtung süden der sprecher des
ukrainischen militärs kommentierte
nüchtern
das vorgehen gegen die besatzung der
ukraine geht weiter
vorstoß der einen rückschlag der anderen
weil die unvorbereitet überrascht wurden
sagen beobachter sehen zwar keine wende
im krieg aber doch einen bemerkenswerten
erfolg wenn es den ukrainern gelingt
silber kräfte nach zu führen und diesen
erfolg auszunutzen also weiter
vorzudringen weiter vorzustoßen dann
kann das für die russen eine
ausgesprochen schwierige situation
werden attackieren kann deren armee in
der region derzeit offenbar nur aus der
luft und tut das frachtschiff stadt
mehrere bomben schlagen ein mindestens
ein mensch stirbt
während sich putins truppen also aus der
region haake zurückziehen bleibt die
stadt attraktiv im visier russlands die
zweitgrößte metropole der ukraine
einzunehmen das bislang mehrfach aber
seit monaten lässt moskau die stadt aus
der luft angreifen in den vergangenen
tagen haben die attacken auf fragte
weiter zugenommen von dort berichtet
katrin eigendorf
mitten in einen kindergarten im zentrum
von hartz iv hat die russische armee
raketen gefeuert tiziana die leiterin
kann es nicht fassen
wieso sagen die russen dass unsere
kinder sterben sollen dass unsere nation
vernichtet werden muss
zum glück war niemand im gebäude
seit wochen schon hat die
stadtverwaltung wegen der gefahr alle
schulen und kindergärten geschlossen
der reebok ist ukrainischer
kriegsfotograf in diesen tagen ist er
ständig unterwegs um die neuen angriffe
auf archiv zu dokumentieren was er
erlebt nimmt ihn sichtlich mit das ist
das drama einer stadt die zerstört wird
und dem terror zum opfer fällt
aufräumarbeiten sind alltag dass die
ukrainische armee im osten und norden
von hf die russischen angreifer
zurückdrängt auch hier macht das
hoffnung doch eine wende im krieg
bedeutet das noch nicht
nichts stört russland trotz aller
erfolge der ukrainischen armee werden
sie weitermachen kharkiv zu beschießen
so chaotisch so ohne ziel wo auch immer
die raketen fallen wen auch immer sie
töten ganz egal
den krieg weiter dokumentieren das ist
seriös ziel dafür wurde er gerade erst
vom ukrainischen präsidenten
ausgezeichnet
bundestagspräsident in bars hat die
entlastungs pakete der ampel koalition
kritisiert sie hätte sich mehr
differenzierung gewünscht um gezielt
dienst schwächsten zu helfen so die
spd-politikerin in der bild zugleich
zeigte sie sich offen für ein viertes
paket das besonders ärmere menschen in
der energiekrise unterstützen solle man
müsse bereit sein noch einmal
nachzulegen
nach großbritannien dort hat drei tage
nach dem tod von queen elizabeth der
zweite ihre letzte reise begonnen heute
wurde der leichnam der königin von
schloss bellevue in die schottische
hauptstadt edinburgh überführt eine
strecke von rund 280 kilometern mit
mehreren zwischenstationen
überall versammelten sich menschen um
ihre queen die letzte ehre zu erweisen
glück weippert
abschloss und ergriffenheit bei
tausenden trauernden als der
leichenwagen mit den sterblichen
überresten der königin am späten
nachmittag in der schottischen
hauptstadt eintrifft ihre letzte reise
begann am morgen auf schloss balmoral
dessen ländliche abgeschiedenheit die
monarchien zeitlebens geschätzt hatte
auch dort tiefe anteilnahme
wir waren im gottesdienst heute früh
alle sehr bewegt als die nationalhymne
gesungen wurde mit dem neuen text die
königin ist tot lang lebe der könig
trauer hier höfisches protokoll dort am
mittag wurde in dem büro die gestern in
london begonnen eine proklamation des
neuen königs fortgesetzt in anwesenheit
zahlreicher würdenträger darunter die
schottische regierungschef in nikolas
töten
nach dem tod unserer liebevoll in
erinnerung bleibenden königin ist der
rechtmäßige nachfolger jetzt charles der
dritte
am rande der veranstaltung kam es
vereinzelt zu protesten gegen die
monarchie zum neuen könig charles gab es
bei den besuchern auch skeptische
stimmen
ich glaube es wird diskussionen geben
wollen wir noch eine monarchie im
vereinigten königreich oder ein
unabhängiges schottland eine mehrheit
der schotten hatte sich 2014 in einer
volksabstimmung gegen die unabhängigkeit
und für den verbleib im vereinigten
königreich entschieden die verstorbene
monarchien wird morgen vom schloss
hollywood haus in die kathedrale
überführt wo die schotten abschied von
ihr nehmen können
vor dieser schottischen residenz der
queen in mv steht diana zimmermann für
uns diana haben die monarchie gegner in
schottland jetzt aufwind
ja heute da der sagt der queen im
thronsaal von hollywood haus steht ist
überwiegt hier ganz klar die trauer aber
es gibt tatsächlich zwei politische
diskussionen die sich in schottland
abzeichnen das eine ist die frage nach
der unabhängigkeit das persönliche wesen
der queen hat das angespannte verhältnis
zwischen schotten und engländern etwas
befriedet jetzt da sie nicht mehr ist
werden unabhängigkeits befürworter
argumentieren binde sie nun wirklich gar
nichts mehr an england ob das reicht um
der unabhängigkeitsbewegung eine stabile
mehrheit zu besorgen ist allerdings
zweifelhaft
es gibt allerdings noch eine zweite
diskussion die hierauf kommen wird
schneller und wahrscheinlich heftiger
als in anderen landesteilen
das ist die frage nach sinn und unsinn
der monarchie die schotten sind
republikanischer ist das reißt der rest
des landes sie betrachten das königshaus
mit mehr skepsis könig charles wird es
schwer haben die schotten davon zu
überzeugen dass die konstitutionelle
monarchie eine staatsform der zukunft
ist für diese einschätzung diana
zimmermann in schottland
schweden wird heute ein neues parlament
es dürfte ein knappes rennen werden
dennoch letzten umfragen liegt das linke
bündnis von ministerpräsident in under
schon beinahe gleichauf mit dem
rechtskonservativen blog hauptthemen im
wahlkampf waren die energiekrise und
zunehmende kriminalität im land davon
profitieren könnten die rechtsradikalen
schwedendemokraten die möglicherweise
zweitstärkste kraft werden
bundespräsident steinmeier befürchtet
dass aufgrund der steigenden preise im
herbst und winter noch mehr menschen in
deutschland ihre wohnung verlieren
anlässlich des tags der wohnung
wohnungslosen besuchten steinmeier und
seine frau heute eine einrichtung der
berliner stadtmission
der bundespräsident forderte mehr
engagement gegen obdachlosigkeit
schätzung zufolge lebten in deutschland
mehr als 300.000 menschen ohne eigenes
zuhause
der spott beginnt mit der formel 1 und
da sieht alles danach aus dass der alte
weltmeister auch ist so der vorsprung
von max verstappen der wächst und wächst
und wächst
weil er rückstände im rennen problemlos
aufholen kann verstappen gewinnt in
monza vor schale claire und hat den
zweiten titel schon vor augen max was
daten dominiert auch beim heimspiel von
ferrari sein fünfter sieg in serie schon
beim start von rang 7 macht der
weltmeister zwei plätze gut nach fünf
runden ist der zweite hinter le claire
im ferrari geht später durch gute
boxenstrategie in führung der aston
martin von sebastian vettel versagt
seinen dienst sein renn ende in runde
zwölf der letzte boxenstopp kurz vor
ende des rennens verstappen bleibt in
führung und fährt hinter dem safetycar
ins ziel 16 saisonrennen elfter sieg mit
schumacher wird zwölfter
union berlin ist aktuell mit zwei
punkten vorsprung bundesliga
tabellenführer nach dem 1 0 in köln kann
aber in diesen minuten noch vom sc
freiburg abgelöst werden die
weltranglisten erste liga steht hat zum
ersten mal die us open in new york
gewonnen im finale gewinnt die polen in
zwei sätzen gegen aussage aus tunesien
ihr dritter grand slam turniersieg nach
zwei erfolgen in paris
sie haben es noch mal spannend gemacht
nach großem vorsprung mit dem 85 79
gegen montenegro erreichen deutschlands
basketballer das em-viertelfinale die
frage ist ob einer der stärksten dann
mitmischen kann es war die situation die
weitreichende folgen für das abschneiden
der deutschen basketballer bei der em
haben kann nba-profi franz wagner
knickte oben konnte danach gegen
montenegro nicht mehr spielen auch heute
noch keine prognose möglich
ich kann ihnen jetzt keine antwort geben
vielleicht sind wir morgen schon ein
bisschen schlauer der knöchel ist
verstaucht wie schlimm das ist schwer zu
sagen
deutschland mit licht und schatten beim
sieg gestern am dienstag geht es um den
einzug ins halbfinale wahrscheinlicher
gegner ist griechenland
drückt man einfach die trauben für ihn
und das team dankeschön arbeit
und so wird das wetter im norden und
osten zahlreiche wolken und etwas sonne
im westen und süden überwiegend sonne
höchsttemperatur 18 bis 26 grad
das heute schon mal können sie um 21 45
sehen mit anne gellinek an dieser stelle
begrüßte hier morgen mitri sirin und
jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit berlin
direkt und theo koll